so these are the charges that we have
had filed a day signed by one of our
Superior Court judges these are the 11
charges against officer Roth the first
charge is felony murder
this is a death that is as a result of a
underlying felony and in this case the
underlying felony is aggravated assault
with a deadly weapon and the possible
sentences for a felony murder conviction
would be life life without parole or the
death penalty now he's also charged by
in in the arrest warrant with aggravated
assault with a deadly weapon and this is
a account charging him for the shooting
of mr. Brooks and the possible sentence
for aggravated assault is 1 to 20 years
so in reaching our decision there were
some considerations that we considered
important and one of the things that we
noted from our evaluation was that mr.
Brooks on the night of this incident was
calm he was cordial and really displayed
a cooperative nature secondly even
though mr. Brooks was slightly impaired
his demeanor during this incident was
almost jovial unfortunately this marks
the 40th prosecution of police officers
for misconduct are here in our County
and this is the ninth time that we've
prosecuted a homicide case committed by
a police officer
eight of those cases involved black
males and one of those cases involved a
black female